hello everybody and welcome back to a
losses we are here in the thingamabob er
I've read all the books and we are ready
to go okay so I need what I need is a
brain that's what I need okay anyway but
what I really need is sanity but what I
really need right now in this game is to
get a water bottle from the kitchen
which you guys told me about and I need
to take the mint these ashes that I
found and for some reason I'm a sham all
up in the mortar and pedestal or pestle
not mortar and pedestal mortar and
pestle on the counter there and go also
I need to find some route I don't know I
don't know I don't know no no but anyway
so I got the water bottle I need to go
into town and fill it up in the fountain
to get the pure water for this recipe to
open a temple and then go into the
temple and stab some demon in the douche
they haven't demon didn't do what am I
even talking about I don't even know I
don't even know but either way I'm a
hopeless basket case who's right on the
edge of sanity and insanity and I'm
walking along this fine line and about
to die a horrible death oh well let's
just get the ashes or water we do have
the ashes still right okay we got a pile
of ashes a bottle mint and we need to
find three other of those stone pieces I
believe whatever I do doing I don't care
all I care about is that I find this
damnable thing and get the heck e heck
out of y'all it's clear water it's full
how we saved that we are doing good
we're doing good all right I need to
collect that blood okay somewhere now
the only thing that I don't know where
to get is this sort of ginseng thing I
think somebody set outside the church
but that probably is a lie I've learned
that a lot of things are lies
I can see something inside so I would
guess that there would be a way to get
in there but I've been wrong woo-woo-woo
what was that you did something there do
it again do it again what you Bob I fell
okay I'm gonna assume that it's not
there don't go I do believe I hate in
this game I do believe this game is doom
I do believe this game is quite terrible
okay anyway alright alright follow me
into the not incorrect area and we will
use this key that we found to unlock the
gates of the temple question mark I'm
assuming cuz that's the only place that
I haven't been way hang on let me
double-check the cemetery because one of
you guys what are you guys you said did
I miss something up here I'm switching
back to the lander and I like the
lantern better anyway
so nice and bright here I don't name is
two one go grumble grumble grumble
grumble grumble grumble grumble grumble
grumble that's all I am just a grumbly
old man hello
someone in here is there a piece of
stone I got a key from a dead body I'm
just gonna assume that there might be
something here do not need hello dirt
pile dirt pile pile of dirt dirt I'm
looking for some dirt have you seen some
dirt
it's about yay high looks like dirt
hello dirt Hey someone took away this
dirt where'd all the dirt go I better
check with this dirt over here hello
dark have you exchanged some dirt it
looked pretty Brown and was earthy kind
of like dirt goes by the name of Earth
if you've ever heard of it before
also known as dirt - in the ground it
actually is the ground have you seen it
ground dirt really fine powdery dirt
have you seen it
a dirt pile to the pile well not really
it's kind of flat but it's dirt have you
seen it no well [ __ ] you din walking
through the woods with my shovel I'm the
scariest monster in this game
no one can tell again my mind and I'll
sing all day where the hell's our
blacksmith where the hell's our
blacksmith where the hell's our
blacksmith hey worked where the hell's
our blacksmith okay I'm done I can't
sing worth a damn and I know you guys
yours are bleeding right now guys and
ladies I can't do the wink and click at
the same time kind of I almost got it
dirt have you seen some dirt dirt hey
are you the dirt I'm looking for dirt
dirt is there some dirt over here that I
hey wait this dirt looks kind of strange
no no this looks looks like NIM regular
dirt okay I was confused I thought I
thought I thought I thought it was dirt
not dirt boy what dirt boys not the
right dirt yeah not my dirt and he might
dirt let's just follow the trail to see
where this goes I don't know where this
temple area is but frankly I do not care
I do I do not I do not care I care not
for this is all stupid hey where does
this lead
hey this dirt path it might lead to some
dirt where was this the shack but not
made of dirt hmm well there's a rock and
a sack well was this say the type of bar
no no you ha ha ha
gaga by suite pro moves epic dodging
epic dodge jumping I'm too proud for you
wolfy get out of here no one likes you
anyway you're ugly you're smelly and you
have no friends Oh what are you lying
about that huh nothing you don't like
any of that ah too bad ah get away
doggie hello honey is that some dirt no
no right dirt Malou Dada Dada that was
dirt I saw that that was definitely dirt
I saw that dirt I'm gonna get that dirt
just as soon as I mess up with this
stupid little doggy here who thinks you
can mess with the lights on me I am too
Pro for you too bro for you
get away doggie where the hell I'm gonna
go back into the dude thingy get the
thing act kinda itchy spy my head I'm
gonna get back and do the thingy but
hopefully this wolf will know what's
best for him cuz I know what's best
an elbow lock into oblivion that's
what's best that's right get away doggy
you can't mess with the likes of me
okay doggy is officially gone now and I
have only ingredient yeah good for me
good for me and all of my hopes and
dreams which are quickly vacating myself
but anyway I have something and
something is better than nothing and
nothing is where I was before so let's
take what we got and try to find our way
to something else coats of inspiration
from markiplier straight to you
hello oh no oh no oh no oh no we got a
douche we got a douche on our trail
first we had a wolf and now there's this
jackass over here
you know when they added NPC threats I
thought for sure they would do something
a little less douchey this whole I'm
gonna name this episode king of the
douches okay we have escaped near
certain death and we have quickly jumped
forward into the mansion area so that we
can get this because half of this game
is just me wandering around the
place I'm not gonna waste any more of
your time so let's get this you come
here with me it wasn't wind what are you
talking about there's no way in hell you
don't want to take the mortar you're
just gonna take the oh here's a bigger
bowl I'm gonna put the ingredients in
the bowl and I'm gonna put it wait a
minute I'm gonna put the ingredients
into a bowl oh I gotta put that first
you kidding me right well what is the
hell what who mix it see place the rest
in greenness of right order
it doesn't matter order doesn't matter
stupid jerk
yeah oh yeah I made a magical mixture of
horrifying nature where to go
Oh what the hell I just drank it right
then and there
what kind of crazy death wish do I have
whatever
I'm now super powerful monster you all
will be ware of the epic blacksmith
hundred markiplier e vh M a [ __ ] HM
ablum beware the ebb him now it's too
bright yet turn off my lantern is too
bright
well now I'm in some ephah real ghost
world and I'm wandering the woods trying
to find or no I'm not trying to find
anything I'll go back to the temple now
right right
are you there mr. torch-wielding bastard
you better not be if you know what's
good for you I'll I'll Drive you into
the dirt sorry this red spot is getting
brighter I don't know what it is but
it's itchy done
I died getting a tie is okay I'm
perfectly fine everybody why are you so
concerned you look worried do not be
worried this is serious this is just the
manifestation of my inner demons from
playing Ollie hook I can't even I can't
even bring up the energy to be silly I
can't do it I can't do it game and
drains me drains my soul right out of my
eyeballs actually through this point in
my head just drains me I wonder what
that is I have no idea what that is
what is that what is it hey whatever I
don't care
some people ever wondered that there was
a red spot on my neck this the if if if
I like have my heart rate goes up you
see this here or something like that for
some reason I'm like overheating I have
scars on my neck that'll show up bright
red it's kind of weird actually I don't
know why but it just is that way got
scars from nah you don't know you'll
never know why I have scars there you'll
never know you'll never know yeah
right can I go in the temple now can I
go in the temple now looks like a
theater
oh it's telling me where the next piece
is all right you know what
you know what so pillar with a hole in
it I'm gonna put this screwdriver right
and I'll I love this shovel all right
whatever
okay I'll be back once I get the piece
from the theater and then some some some
thumbs up tomorrow so be back oh oh no
not you
oh you can't mess with the likes of me
I'm super powerful now and you're such
an [ __ ] that I can't even begin even
be good oh no oh come on
no I hate this game I had no luck you
got me okay you gotta be joking me all
right I'm done for now
cuz holy hell that is stage the
stupidest thing ever but they were gonna
add NPC threats to the woods why would
they have them stand in the same exact
place where I need to go and then
suddenly there's a cutscene he gets me
why am i holding my hands like this
I mean anymore nothing makes sense the
world is a lie everything's a lie
everything in the zoo a game is a lot
who think lie there's good it stupid a
game dumb I like it
bad I'll finish it I'm a fish it
obviously I'm an official pump running
preliminary judgment on it it's not
scary
I was never immersed in the story Oh
story sucks anyway oh you know anyone
like this game yeah
I'm just being highly emotional right
now
but I pass judgment on this game is
stupid okay anyway I'll finish this up
soon a bench is up in one more episode
imma finish this sumbitch
but not now video
ah
pop up here
ha
doctor
ah
Oh
but
Oh